okay so this is basic front kick
watch your sympathetic tension
so you go to and you have that
and you pull it in your hands
or your leg is coming up
and you're losing your ground vector as
you come up
so keep it as a release stroke i hit the
bag
i have the intention of hitting the bag
but my mind is not
going into any sort of attachment
it is being fluid not attached
just keep it at this pace where you can
keep your form
and pay attention that you can control
your
landing and it's just as dynamic
as the first stance
just decide now okay
okay so my dynamic stance i can try to
land
in it but if i don't land in it let's
say
oh then move the other foot so you do
end up in it
it's not gymnastics where you have to
land like this and you lose a point for
taking a step
okay find your dynamic stance again all
right
because you're going to probably have to
use that now so this
is a technique timing technique
so he's coming to close the gap boom and
i'm going to throw that front kick in
that sweet spot
okay so he goes boom and i'll throw that
frost kick there so we're gonna do it on
the back
and it's a little different for the back
holder you're gonna have to trust the
foam technology
do not shove this bag into that person
just hold it tight and
i will start further out of range and he
will walk into ray's room
and i'm going to do that same kick so
he's not going to shove the bag at me
he's just going to let the phone
technology do its job again i'm not
trying for power
so it's not going to kill him he goes
and i find that dynamic stance again
what i don't want to happen i'm out of
range
i'm jamming i'm looking for that sweet
spot
and now i'm not going backwards because
i'm not up here
without the ground vector he hits the
ground
okay now he doesn't have the bag
and we want to play with that dynamic
stance
okay so he goes i have the timing drill
boom let's do it from up from mcgartha
here he comes right
boom and he's going to come in again and
i'm going to help him
sometimes your doesn't work comes
back
it comes right back in the kick
boom
so when i do this move my hands have to
be under his hips
okay it's another time you move i gotta
hit it right in that sweet spot
and then i have this mid-foot vectoring
i'm not like this mid-foot vectoring and
as he goes over
i move past him
i don't stand still i don't want him
grabbing onto me
you can brush the legs if you need it
sweet spot
so again there's not two arts there's
only one art
so he comes in it says sweet
he comes in i guide under
he's got a lot of yarn on top the yin is
on the bottom
but i can't go young on the bottom i
can't go like this
i still have to blend i still have to
internally yield
and then i'll get the ip adhesion and
then he'll go over my
hips
and i don't get pinned
so same drill i kind of demonstrated
accidentally we're just gonna change the
timing okay
so he comes in boom i had the sweet spot
and i'm going into him
i'm not gonna wait for him like in the
basement i'm not waiting here
and then okay boom boom
so a little slower one boom i'm moving
it boom
[Music]
okay again working on on having that
dynamic stance okay
so he comes in i work on the sweet spot
this time he's gonna
knock him in he's gonna allow a yin
space to generate maybe i kicked him so
hard
which does happen usually usually a guy
doesn't
come back in after that kid but let's
say uh
last one he did this one he doesn't okay
so i do the kick
i'm gonna close the gap so that i am
dynamic
and i'm gonna come in to the double leg
takedown
okay um but we're gonna have it a little
different than last time so his weight
is coming
forward almost like he's gonna sprawl
okay
so he's you're gonna feel that and
you're going to take the
front inward kazushi so he goes
so sweet spot i'm going in
the legs he's i can feel his weight
so i'm going to take him around me boom
boom can i feel his weight
sorry
i don't care what you do afterwards i'm
interested in
boom this part here where i'm moving
dude last time you gave me an immediate
give me
so this foot goes from the kick
forward boom
into chicago
i'm very forgiving this time let's
control
our uh landing all right so again
working on these transitions okay so he
goes i do get a drill on the sweet spot
and then i'm working the same sweet spot
in
this time i'm gonna stay with him
control
wow
okay this time